i got a bunch of fun questions and
hopefully
you guys don't mind so who do you think
is the strongest character in the game
and who is the strongest character in
the movie i think the strongest
character in the game was always
uh liu kang for me just because he's so
cheap and overpowered
his cheap leg sweeps his bicycle kicks
that nobody can escape
once you get hit and how much damage
he actually takes off of one hit is
crazy and then raiden too
once you master raiden i think he's
almost unbeatable
um and in the movie in the movie maybe i
think raiden
or uh yeah for me it would be raining as
well he doesn't do anything
and that gets you that gets me very
frightened
yeah it's just the thunder god right i
mean who can beat raiden i think
um he's pretty much on top
um i i think sonia actually like a
female
strong female character in the in in the
movie i think um
yeah she quite stands out okay did you
guys joke around at all and decide
what your friendship would be if it was
portrayed in the movie
yeah our friendship would be a mortal
kombat musical
the entire the entire movie done again
after credit's role in musical form
yeah i think i would use um kung lao's
hat to
first of all buy a cake for everyone and
then slice it
with my hat and give everyone a piece
i like that that's great um who do you
think
has the most brutal fatality in the game
oh gosh there's a lot i think
he's always pretty hilarious yeah
i think kano does some pretty sick [ __ ]
i mean
stabbing someone with a beer bottle and
killing him off and dancing around with
the skeleton
got it maybe kano i i think a lot of
people like to learn
stuff that they don't know about the
making of a movie and i'm curious
uh for mortal kombat for making the film
what do you think might surprise people
to learn
about the making of the film or the
behind the scenes
um okay well i got one um
and i'll speak for lou kang uh because
in
the very beginning when i went for a
fitting
um as soon as i got in there i realized
that they planned they didn't plan the
headband for liu kang
so then this all along i didn't want i
think people are going to get send me
death threats i was worried about that
if that didn't show up in the movie so i
tried hard to find a place to fit it in
and the place in the movie where i found
um
it worked perfectly and i pitched it to
uh simon our director he loved it
and it just took a lot of coordinating
to actually make that happen
and i'm glad we were able to do it in
the end yeah i mean um
for me it must have been the hat um
putting it on for the first time
because it was so heavy and when i um
prepped for the movie um before that i
used like my own hat
made out of cardboard and i would try
all these you know flips and spins and
move
and it worked out pretty well but once i
tried on the the real hat it was like oh
my god
do i have to how can i even pull off
those those movements
with with this this hat so that was
quite interesting um on that note i got
to stop
i'm just gonna say i really hope it's a
huge hit and you guys get to make
another one
awesome everyone's thinking thank you
thank you chris
steve